automation with robotics is becoming a
differentiator in the manufacturing the
skills you need to know for a career in
this robotics field are teaching at the
fastest rate in history at Udacity our
goal is to empower you with the
real-world relevant skills that make you
successful at your job today and prepare
you for the jobs of tomorrow our self
driving car nano degree program allowed
students the exclusive opportunity to
put their code on a real self-driving
car now our robotics students will have
the opportunity to control real I am a
professor of computer science at Cancer
Institute of Technology in Germany
students will have the opportunity to
program these robots the experience with
working with physical robots is very
different from working with robots and
simulation this is something very unique
you cannot find us in any other online
program and even at many universities
it's very rare to get access to real
top-notch Hardware join Udacity robotic
software engineer a nano degree program
to learn the latest in robotics software
technology and gain access to this
exciting opportunity we look forward to
seeing you in the class
[Music]